la délégation sénatorielle aux outre-mer
auditionnent cet après-midi monsieur
Gabriel servile président de la
collectivité territoriale de Guyane dans
le cadre de la préparation de son
rapport sur l'évolution institutionnelle
des Outre-mer je vous rappelle que nous
avons déjà entendu les exécutifs de
Saint-Barthélémy la réunion ou à laisser
Futuna Saint-Martin
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et la Polynésie
française nous auditionnerons jeudi
prochain le président du conseil
départemental de Mayotte les élus de
Guyane se sont réunies en congrès le 26
mars 2022 et ont exprimé leur souhait
d'une inscription du territoire dans la
Constitution en tant que collectivité
territoriale autonome un statut
particulier pour l'Anjou ainsi la
demande de collectivité suis généreuse
portée par vos prédécesseurs
nous sommes donc intéressés par le bilan
que vous dressez de l'organisation
institutionnelle actuelle la Guyane et
par la présentation de vos propositions
d'évolution ou d'adaptation je vais vous
donner la parole monsieur le Président
pour un exposé liminaire sur la base du
questionnaire qui vous a été adressé au
plat préalable pour préparer cette
audition je vous interrogerai ensuite
ainsi que mes collègues
[Musique]
qui est la chef
et ainsi que madame Isabelle Verde que
vous pouvez très bien l'image parce que
un petit peu décalé qui est chargé de la
réussite de scolaire de la région
éducative et puis sur une coach qui
n'est pas visible aussi à l'écran de
mettre Olivier thermique et aussi
spécial pour tout ce qui tourne autour
du jur
qui nous accompagne aussi sur cette
problématique de l'évolution sanitaire
un directeur de cabinet il est ainsi
juste derrière moi donc ce qu'on a pas
que certainement vous avez connu
ici à des autres mères il y a quelques
années de ça madame analyse résidente je
vous remercie pour le temps que vous
allez nous consacrer tout est de
comprendre comment le processus a été
engagé en Guyane et une commande nous
avons intentions de le faire évoluer
simplement je souhaiterais vous dire ma
circonspection sur la nature même de
et je le dis sans mettre en cause les
personnes qui en sont à l'origine
puisque j'étais complètement
et je sais à quel point je me suis
débattu pour pouvoir faire
autant une voix très singulière de nos
territoires et en particulier
viennent mais nous avons les convictions
que cela fait trop longtemps que nous
réfléchissons aux modalités supplément
faire évoluer les cadres statutaires de
nos territoires respectifs même si tous
les territoires ne sont pas alignés sont
des développeurs avec la lune subjectifs
alors j'ai tenté en 2018 lorsque le
personnage il avait engagé cette
révision de la constitution de faire une
entendre une voix différente concernant
la liberté
fasse objet du description aussi de la
Constitution souvent un article qui
serait spécialement un métier suivant le
cadre
qui prendrait en considération ce que
sont les vérités objectives de ce
territoire il se trouve que l'affaire
Benalla est passé et qui nous
empêchaient d'aller jusqu'au bout
du brevet été engagé et c'est pour cette
raison essentiellement que
dans
le
je voudrais une fois exposé ce midi
chiant rappelé quelque chose qui
pourront être fondamental et qui risque
d'être une grosse banane sous pied si de
notre prenons pas le temps d'en parler
nous qui sommes originaires
pour une évolution de nos institutions
il s'agit du préambule même de la
Constitution
je tâcherai de le dire assez rapidement
parce que je comprends que ce n'est pas
l'essentiel
que nous aurons aujourd'hui mais il est
pourtant pour moi de rappeler que ce
préambule qui est le siège des droits et
des libertés qui sont constituellement
garanties constitue selon moi le
véritable hiatus constitutionnel et
démocratique je l'appelle ici en disant
que les termes ne sont pas trop forts de
la mesure où on s'en aliné à deux c'est
ce planning dispose que en vertu de ses
principes et de celui de la libre
détermination des peuples la République
offre au territoire d'outre-mer qui
manifeste la volonté d'y atterrir
qu'est-ce que l'institutions nouvelles
fondées sur l'idéal commun de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité et conçu au
vu de leur évolution démocratique ce que
j'avais expliqué à l'époque c'était que
ce groupe de la Constitution avait été
rédigé avant la phase de décolonisation
qui a connu les pays notamment
notamment d'Afrique subsaharienne il se
trouve que
cette rédaction a été antérieure aux
années 60 et que même après que la
France est opéré le décolonisation cette
rédaction est toujours restée dans le
but de la constitution de 1900 58 et qui
offre une vision assez érodée pour ne
pas dire foncièrement erroné de ce que
sont le territoire parce que c'est
alinéa par le des territoires outre-mer
donc les territoires d'outre-mer qui est
sorti aujourd'hui c'est la Martinique
c'est la Guyane c'est la Guadeloupe la
Réunion
c'est tous ces territoires qui sont
parfaitement ancrés de la Constitution
puisque ils seront cités de la
Constitution et quand on regarde cette
rédaction qui est toujours d'actualité
elle laisserait à penser que nous
serions toujours
dit que nous serions toujours des
territoires qui n'auraient pas encore
été créé la République puisque
la lumière dit bien que
la République offre à cette territoire à
la possibilité d'adhérer au principe de
liberté d'égalité fraternité en vue de
les accompagner vers leur évolution
démocratique
aussi vous donner d'autres glaces c'est
la même démocratie sauf si je ne m'abuse
que celle que l'on retrouve en France
hexagonale nous avons des élections
présidentielles législatives des exos
communales des expressions sénatoriales
qui se déroulent au même moment dans
tous les territoires
de décalage entre le samedi et dimanche
pour une raison principaux pratiques que
tout le monde connaît mais
fondamentalement je pense que au départ
il y a quelque chose qui ne nous
convient pas du tout dans ce que recule
et je pense que il va falloir que l'on
prenne le temps d'expliquer à notre
gouvernement que de deux choses une ou
bien il considèrent ces territoires
comme faisant partie intégrante de la
République parce que cela fait très
longtemps qu'on y a adhéré ou alors il
faudrait considérer que nous sommes en
dehors de la République et je pense que
au départ cela devrait nécessiter à me
poser de façon différente les questions
conc la façon dont on va faire évoluer
nos institutions donc voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire comme le
compromiminaire avant que d'aborder les
différentes questions que vous nous avez
posé
justement alors concernant ce
questionnaire madame la Présidente je ne
sais pas comment vous avez procédé avec
les autres personnes qui ont été
conditionnées à moi ce que je
souhaiterais
c'est que nous prenions un temps pour
pouvoir avec les collègues qui
m'accompagnent avoir des bas qui ne
porteraient pas nécessairement sur les
questions telles qu'elles figure dans le
questionnaire et que on s'accorde la
possibilité de vous faire des réponses
par écrit parce que le travail que j'ai
des yeux c'est une réponse qui a été
construite à plusieurs fois et je me dis
que on aurait voulu par exemple
vous voulez faire parvenir par écrit
avec la précision nécessaire à la fois
dans la construction de la réponse est
dans la construction sémantique
également
que les choses ne soient bien comprises
par une sémantique et par le vocabulaire
qui soit adapté qui soit oublié et que
j'aurais de préférence
voulu réserver ce temps d'échange parce
qu'on m'a dit que nous disposons d'une
petite demi-heure seulement réservé ce
temps d'échange à
je veux dire une discussion qui serait
plus sympa
à deux actualités par rapport au congrès
de Guyane par rapport à l'appel de
France par rapport aux différents
contacts que nous avons eu très
récemment avec le président de la
République notamment lors du 7 septembre
par rapport à tout ce qu'il a pu dire ce
qu'il a pu annoncer comme état d'esprit
nouveau nous permettant de pouvoir
sereinement envisager de travailler à la
rédaction de ce nouveau statut à la cour
constitution de cet engagement entre la
Guyane et le gouvernement et qu'il
devrait dans The laps de temps très
court que nous permettre d'arriver aux
résultats scooter alors pourquoi est-ce
que je vous fais cette proposition
simplement justement parce que nous
considérons que le temps qui nous est
compté aujourd'hui et de temps qui est
vraiment très court le président de la
République a clairement dit dès le
départ que la question de l'évolution
statutaire n'était pas une question
d'amour et nous a aussi dit que nos
études arrivés au bout de cycle et que
par ailleurs il nous faudrait penser à
changer
parce que le logiciel que nous utilisons
actuellement est surdé il est devenu
caduc et il n'arrive plus à nous
permettre de répondre à nos véritables
interrogations il a aussi dit que il
fallait pas avoir peur d'aller vers
certaines qualités pour faire la
démonstration à nos concitoyens que nous
étions dans une bonne dynamique pour
faire évoluer le cadre institutionnels
et faire évoluer la nature même des
politiques publiques qui sont mises en
place sur nos différents territoires je
pense que c'est ces discussions que nous
avons avec le président de la République
au-delà même des réponses que je dois
apporter de manière très précise par
rapport aux questions d'air qui nous a
été adressées sans selon moi et sera les
personnes qui m'accompagnent les
fondamentaux très importants à partir
desquels on va devoir construire le
nouveau paradigme sur lequel la Guyane
et les autres territoires des autres
berbes vont pouvoir s'appuyer pour faire
entendre une voix qui soit différente de
celle qu'on a pu produire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et je crois que si la
délégation
sénatoriale d'outre-mer avait travaillé
nous franc à produire ça serait
justement de pouvoir prendre au mot les
différents membres d'ouverture le
président de la République d'abord qui
ont l'article par rapport à l'article de
la Constitution et garant des
institutions et qui auront de
l'intégrité du territoire également du
respect des conventions et des normes
qui sont passés et nous nous disons que
la parole qui a été prononcée par le
Président de la République est une
parole forte en soi doit pouvoir être
une espèce de guide une espèce de fil
conducteur qui va permettre à notre
territoire de pouvoir s'engager
résolument sur la base de des
fondamentaux que nous avons été gagnant
alors je le dis encore une fois sur la
question du temps le Président nous
expliquer que il aurait été au porteur
que la Guyane puisse travailler très
rapidement en vue de bénéficier de la
fenêtre de tir même si le
que vous avez pas cette expression peut
être de dire parce qu'elle est
connotation trop guérir mais moi je
l'avais répondu que nous sommes dans un
pays où on lance des fusées et que
l'expression fait d'être du tir nous est
très coutumière et il nous avait suggéré
fortement d'établir un calendrier du
travail qui nous permettrait d'arriver
avec un document
unique avec une loi organique qui soit
négligée avec une consultation de la
population qui aurait déjà pu être faite
sur la base d'une date butoir fin 2023
début de l'année 2024 pour pouvoir nous
associer à ce travail qui serait fait
concernant la révision optionnelle sur
le cadre de la Nouvelle-Calédonie donc
l'idée c'est d'associer la Guyane pour
qu'elle puisse emprunter ce train c'est
vraiment au niveau de conduire à cet
objectif et donc cela veut dire en clair
que en faisant aller au planning on va
se retrouver dans une dynamique
extrêmement contrainte alors cette
dynamique devrait compter de le nombre
de séances de travail entre le
gouvernement et le comité de pilotage
qui porte la question de l'évolution
statutaire où il avec le progrès des
élus de Guyane qui devrait faire ce
travail de co-construction sur un
certain nombre de thématiques qui
passerait naturellement en revue une
partie des questions qui figurent à
l'intérieur du questionnaire que
dire que nous sommes vraiment nous ne
sommes pas au début à proprement parler
de processus puisque il est déjà
largement engagé mais nous avons
effectivement conscience qui nous reste
très très lourd et très très long chemin
à parcourir pour pouvoir arriver aux
résultats final voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous dire je suis désolé si
je suis vraiment très long de cette
partie parce que je considère que il est
important pour nous que de poser le
cadre et puis que l'on soit sûr que on
va pouvoir avancer ensemble en fonction
des objectifs que nous serions co-fixé
dès le départ
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
donc avant de poursuivre l'échange
j'aimerais aussi saluer le président
Stephen Artano qui nous qui nous suit
qui ne peut malheureusement pas
intervenir mais mais qui qui a nos côtés
qui est très attentif à cette audition
j'aurais aimé aussi vous rassurer sur le
fait que le Sénat c'est la
représentation justement des
collectivités et que le travail que nous
sommes en train de poursuivre
actuellement c'est un travail qui avait
débuté par mon prédécesseur Michel
maghre sur la différenciation
territoriale et qui avait abouti un
rapport différenciation territoriale
outre-mer quel cadre pour le sur mesure
déjà très tôt il était il s'est
intéressé à tous ces problèmes
rencontrés à travers les différents
territoires ultramarins et l'objectif de
de cette audition c'est justement de
recadrer puisque vous avez dans tous les
territoires nous avons en grande
majorité de nouveaux exécutifs et de
pouvoir réactualiser ce rapport donc
c'est l'objectif de cette réunion et
comme vous l'avez dit après arriver par
la discussion à construire parce que et
ce n'est pas le Sénat qui fera le
travail à votre place il appartiendra à
chaque territoire de décider ce qu'ils
ont envie ce qu'ils veulent et pour leur
territoire évidemment le Sénat viendra
en qualité de
d'accompagnateurs et sera là pour porter
la voix de tous les territoires dans le
respect je le rappelle de chaque donc je
suis tout à fait favorable à échanger
avec vous et puis je recevrai avec avec
plaisir le les réponses aux questions de
manière précise
d'accord d'accord donc
je ne sais pas si parce que je vous dis
encore une fois c'est sûr de gestion de
temps comment faire pour gérer au mieux
donc je pourrais entamer les réponses
par rapport au questionnaire que nous
avons dressé c'est vraiment je ne suis
pas persuadé qu'il faudra le temps de
façon toutes les questions donc on
essaiera d'aller dans l'ordre
chronologique tel que cela nous avait
été adressé la première question était
de savoir quel bilan entière de
l'organisation
actuelle du coup de vue de l'exercice
des
de l'efficacité de la copie des publics
et de l'adaptation de ces politiques aux
réalités des besoins du territoire alors
moi je vous dirais que on tire un bilan
qui est mitigé pour ne pas dire bilan
est satisfaisant
certes la collectivité territoriale de
Guyane tel qu'elle est conçu depuis
la loi de documents
2016 a constitué une avancée réelle par
rapport à la situation précédente car
elle a permis plus de moyens de
l'efficacité pour autant on va revenir à
la Commission les limites de ces
institutionnelles résultant notamment
des normes et des obstacles conjugués à
la difficulté de trouver de nouveaux
leviers financiers constituent des prix
forts de blocage tant que c'est à partir
de ce premier élément d'analyse que
toutes les fois couvergent pour dire que
il faut arriver à lever ces normes qui
ne sont pas conçues pour le territoire
de la Guyane et qui ne prennent pas du
tout en considération ce que sont nos
réalités la deuxième question c'était
avec vous des exemples d'action de
stratégie de projet en travée ou bloqué
par l'organisation exceptionnelle et
normative actuelle
lors des exemples quand il y en auront
pagaille
nous en propose deux ou trois juste pour
illustrer le propos en commençant
d'abord par
l'idée qui a été faite au territoire
lyonnais de pouvoir exposer les côtes du
territoire pour la recherche des
hydrocarbures tout ça pourquoi parce que
la collectivité régionale avait la
compétence pour délivrer les permis
d'exploration et puis se trouve que
juste après la loi Hulot cette
compétence est devenue caduque et
empêche la Guyane de regarder son destin
en face il se trouve que aujourd'hui sur
les côtes de l'Amérique du Sud les
phrasés les pays limitrophes sont en
train de mener de très très beaux de
très beaux travaux d'exploration des
ressources pétrolières je pense
notamment Brésil je consomme sur une
table je pense que qui dans quelques
années de pays extraordinairement des
propriétés parce que on y a trouvé une
source intéressante très intéressante de
carburant alors c'est vrai que on
regarde ce que disent après de Paris
pour aller vers la décarbonation pour
aller vers tout ce qui pourrait
permettre de lutter contre
ceux qui les font en Guyane c'est ce
sentiment d'iniquité des justiciers sous
l'aiguillages que à côté de chez eux il
y a des territoires qui vont pouvoir se
développer qui vont pouvoir aller vers
le pionnier pourquoi s'aménager
s'équiper durablement et nous qui allons
devoir rester éternellement avec cette
politique de béton dû à continuer à
démonter les quelques sous qui me sont
donnés par le National et par l'Europe
et ça c'est vraiment une situation qui
pose problème on a vu dernièrement
toutes les difficultés que nous avons
éprouvées à pouvoir les planter une
centrale électrique du côté du Larivée à
cause de loi le sur l'environnement qui
a été mise en exergue par des
associations de protection de
l'environnement et qui a entraîné des
mesures de justice qui ont un
véritablement
entamé entravé le processus d'évolution
de ce projet de construction d'une
nouvelle centrale pour la production
d'électricité et
je trouve que la Guyane a connu très
récemment deux ou trois ou la carte qui
nous font penser que si on ne réagit pas
très très rapidement pour trouver la
réponse à cette question on risquerait
de vivre des situations peut-être
extrêmement compliqué dans les années
qui viennent la question est aussi posée
par rapport à notre capacité à nous
approvisionner auprès de nos voisins au
carburant et qui fait que nous avons des
carburants les plus chers sur le
continent
américains tout ça parce que il y a un
certain nombre de normes de loi qui
entravent notre capacité à pouvoir
avancer sereinement un autre point qui
pose situation le compte très souvent
c'est le fait qu'on ne puisse pas
disposer du foncier comme on le
respecter puisque vous savez que 80
15%, 90 % pardon du foncier et pour
éviter de l'État on n'a pas beaucoup de
Français à ménager et chaque fois que
l'on s'oriente vers des projets de
construction d'équipements situés
c'est la loi et la prière qui entraîne
de toute une série de difficultés qui
bloquent l'évolution du territoire je
pourrais également citer la loi
littorale qui s'applique de façon
incohérente sur l'intégralité du
territoire usagé et qui pose de
véritables contraintes en matière
d'aménagement du territoire lorsqu'on a
voulu par exemple aller une USB pour
gérer les déchets de méningis de Guyane
et bien tout de suite on s'est rendu
compte que c'était pas possible parce
que on était enfanté à la mise en
application et au respect de la loi mais
qui n'a pas et qui n'ayant pas été conçu
pour la configuration du territoire du
Hadet pose certainement de problèmes
auxquels nous avons beaucoup de mal à
trouver les historique France de vous
citer par exemple que cela alors c'est
vrai que lors de mes derniers passages
sur certains médias j'ai fait les bouts
du cours en expliquant que on nous
obligeait à importer du bois de hêtre de
l'Union européenne pour
alors que cela fait des décennies pour
ne pas dire des siècles que l'aiguènes
avaient l'habitude de boucané leur
viande avec le poids du Guyane
territoire ouvert à 80 15% de forêt
tropicale de forêt primaire c'est
vraiment une espèce de paradoxe qui fait
mal au cœur de savoir qu'on est obligé
de faire venir du bois du bureau payé
pour pouvoir confectionner fabriquer de
viande boucané en Guyane et là c'est
encore une partie de l'économie de la
guerre qui se retrouve les trucs
bizarres ces moments parce que nous
demande de respecter ces directives et
ça c'est quelques
illustrer le propos de judiciaire que
nous tenons lorsque nous disons que ces
normes créent des situations de blocage
que l'on devrait lever très très
rapidement
la question suivante c'est est-ce que
nous souhaiterions
exercer des compétences de nouveaux
domaines notamment des compétences
normatives aller versatile des
compétences que vous souhaiteriez
restituer à l'état contenu soit de la
difficulté à les exercices soit du mode
désiré d'une gestion territoriale alors
la réponse est oui trois fois oui et le
millier de fois oui pour ceux qui
concerne la gestion de l'environnement
pour ceux cancer de la pêche
l'agriculture l'énergie la biodiversité
le sport le transport le logement le
bâtiment les hydrocarbures la fiscalité
les programmes scolaires j'ai envie de
vous mettre un des bonus suspensions je
je pense que je vous fais en ce moment
par écrit mais c'est vous dire que à
chaque fois que nos parcourons une
thématique nous voyons une foule de
situation normale qui pose des
contraintes et qui nous empêche
d'évoluer favorablement tu l'avais dit
pendant que j'étais dégoûté que il
fallait que dans les études d'impact
peut donner des motifs bonsoir en
capacité de passant en revue les effets
bénéfiques mais aussi les effets
contraignants de la mise en application
des lois sur nos territoires de les
collègues députés il m'avait répondu que
cela risquait d'alourdir
considérablement les études d'impacts
qui précède l'écriture de la loi qui
précède son analyse cela étant dit je
considère que si on ne peut pas le faire
dans ce sens il faudrait mieux que on
donne la possibilité à ces territoires
d'outre-mer de pouvoir faire leur propre
loi pays en verront venir ultérieurement
les lois pays qui passeraient
naturellement
du Conseil constitutionnel parce que
l'objectif que nous recherchions se
débat du tout de couper le cordon
médical c'est de dire que notre
République à travers sa constitution
devrait se rentrer un petit peu plus
intelligente à faire de nous permettre
dès le départ de pouvoir rédiger les
normes qui vont nous permettre de durer
pendant nos inspirations qui à ce que
c'est normal soit revue corriger ou
combattu par le Conseil constitutionnel
dès lors où ce conseil viendrait à se
rendre compte que c'est donc serait
contraire à l'esprit même de la de la
République s'il y a une compétence sur
laquelle nous sommes en train de
réfléchir et d'incombrer demander la
restitution comme cela a été fait déjà
pour le RSA antérieurement qu'on arrive
ici c'est la compétence de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance parce que plus on
avance dans le temps le plus on se rend
compte que c'est un véritable sac de 2
avec des obligations qui sont faites au
conseiller généraux et donc au Conseil
territoriaux que nous sommes en Guyane
peut-être pas forcément avec les moyens
adaptés à la définition des politiques
des politiques publiques en matière donc
c'est vraiment une question que nous
sommes en train de nous poser la
décision vous l'aurez compris n'est pas
encore prise mais nous sommes une
véritablement sur cette interrogation de
savoir comment les choses
vont faire
avant qu'elle appréciation de vos sur la
prise en compte des spécificités des
Outre-mer lors de l'élaboration des lois
et des graines quelle méthode
permettrait de l'améliorer
là-dessus
j'ai eu une appréciation qui est très
réservée puisque notre collectivité
territoriale de Guyenne et souvent
consulter tardivement mais il est
quasiment jamais de compte de ces
observations à titre d'exemple pour ceux
qui concerne le coup de bélier je
rappelle que la loi du 22 août 2021
contre lutte contre le direct le mot
climatique et renforcements de la
résilience face à ces effets par son
Article 81 a autorisé le gouvernement à
prendre des ordonnances pendant une
période de mois pour les former le code
de milliers par courrier du 14 pardon du
4 mars
le Préfet de la Région Guyane a en
application de l'article
71-52 de 61 52-2 excuses du quotidien
les collectivités ces eaux il se doit la
collectivité territoriale de plus en
demande de la vie cette demande concerne
plusieurs ordonnances et décrées la vie
de la CDG devait être émis avant le 4
avril 2022 donc vous rendez compte que
le courrier et Laté du 4 mars 2022 et
nous devons donner la vie quasiment
avant moi dans le bois qui suit c'est
les matériellement impossible pour nous
de pouvoir le prendre en considération
cette cette question là et donc on a
émis la vie mais qui est arrivé on a
répondu on a répondu le 30 mars dans les
délais petit temps dans l'oreillette
mais vous rendez bien compte que entre
le courrier et puis la vie rendue a BCE
un vrai parcours
c'est l'ordonnance relative en juridique
aux objectifs de modèles mini-français
aux conditions d'attribution des
demandes des distribués
dedans un territoire de milliers par
excellence et l'ordonnance drone dans la
CPG a adopter des générations une
délibérations le 30 mars 2022 dans
laquelle elle a aimé favorable à
plusieurs dispositions cependant aucune
des observations que la CPG émise n'a
été retenue c'était un avis donc
finalement pour la forme bon on sait
bien que la Guyane recèle de beaucoup de
gizmoteur et sans doute hydrocarbure le
nouveau copier et tous ces moments
inadapté à la configuration de notre
territoire et pourtant il va s'appliquer
pendant les cinq prochaines années en
Guyane avec les conséquences extrêmement
désastreuses que l'on connaît
c'est justement pour illustrer à quel
point nos avis ne sont pas prises en
considération dans la production de
normes et de loi au niveau national et
parfois des conséquences également au
niveau européen la question suivante
c'est ce que la Guyane la Guyane est
soumise au principe d'une vieillissative
le passage au principe de spécialités
souhaitable dans certains domaines si
oui lesquels là je pense que je risque
de faire une petite puisque cela nous
paraît plus que nécessaire c'est même
indispensable à ce niveau de la
réflexion et j'avais précédemment cité
toute une série de thé qui par ailleurs
je préfère vous le dire quand c'est déjà
feront l'objet de
doucement qui aura lieu dans le cadre
des travaux que nous avons entreprendre
nous la reconstruction avec le
gouvernement pour aller vers l'évolution
du Canada et comme je vous l'ai dit
précédemment ce sont les thématiques qui
tournent autour de l'environnement de la
veille scolaire de la culture de
l'énergie en réalité c'est tout ce qui
fait le quotidien de la politique et
tout ce qu'il fait le quotidien des
habitants de ce territoire question
numéro 6 qui est la pression pour qu'il
vous sur les mécanismes qui permettent
en application des 3e et quatrième année
de l'article 73 de la constitution de
solliciter des agriculations à adapter
les normes les domaines de compétences
de l'État sont-ils fonctionnels alors je
vous ferai grâce de la lecture de la
Ligue 1 des alliés de l'article 73 de la
Constitution et de tous ceux qui prévoit
mais moi je vous dirais que c'est à
disposition peuvent être sollicités en
attendant l'évolution statutaire de la
Guyane mais je rappelle que cette
processus qui est très très lent on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler c'est de
véritable parcours du combattant
et la du Sud je considère non
considérant que ça ne peut pas être la
solution à nos problèmes en plus d'être
un parcours du combattant saucisse et
dispositions avaient été modifiées mais
on a découvert que les habitations
tenues tombées avec la fée de la monture
qui les avait porté et que sur la
manature suivante si on voulait
encore bénéficier de ses habitations
mais qui aurait fallu reprendre le
processus de
zéro comme si
jamais réalisé avec l'alternance
démocratique que l'on peut imaginer au
niveau du Sénat et de la sauver
nationale qui pourrait conduire à un
refus de leur délivrance à nouveau donc
on se dit que là dessus c'était très
très belle idée en soi mais dans la
pratique on se rend bien compte que
c'est une idée qui ne peut pas être
viable dans tous les cas nous n'allons
pas nous aussi attarder parce que selon
nous ce n'est pas la solution recherchée
par les territoires de nos enfants la
responsabilité d'organisation concernant
justement l'organisation des
institutions et les règles de
fonctionnement de la collectivité
territoire de Guyane ou de moitié est-ce
que elles sont satisfaisantes avez-vous
relevés des points de blocage des
distances seulement des problèmes des
termes de personnalités
la vérité de nature à améliorer
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
alors je lui dis nous le disons tous que
l'avènement de la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane de la
collectivité unique la constitué une
avancée certaine mais le manque de
moyenne et la dépendance encore trop
forte à l'égard de l'État et nous le
rapport à l'état constitue des points de
blocage cependant j'ai envie de dire que
contrairement à la Martinique ce cadre
est situé n'a pas créé de blocage
particulier qui n'a pas créé de blocage
du tout
puisque le contumium de compétences qui
a été créé lorsque l'on a fait le rack
on a mis côte à côte les lycées
entre la région et le département d'une
part quand on a rapproché les cours des
routes quand on a embauché le
développement économique de la
protection sociale de dire que ce
continent de compétences de crier n'a
pas été toxique au Soi et il faut
peut-être que vous voyez pour gérer ces
différentes additions sectorielles et
véritablement un vrai et c'est une
question qui est vraiment lancinante que
ce moyen de nous permet pas de répondre
correctement aux attentes de la
population
la question numéro 8 concerne la prise
en compte des populations américaines
est-ce que cette mise au côté suffisante
faut-il aller plus loin si oui cela
peut-il se faire dans le cadre
Sagittaire actuel de l'article 73 de la
Constitution alors nous avons envie de
dire que à droite constant nous allons
pouvoir continuer dans le renforcement
du rôle du grand conseil que tu viens
des populations américaines et boucher
des gay et notamment pour voir aussi
continuer dans les travaux de mise en
place de l'établissement public de
coopération culturelle et rapidement
l'environnemental qui a été créé pour
organiser la rétrocession des 400 000
hectares qui est une question qui avait
été fondamentale dans le cadre des
accords de Guyane Dieu est décédé en
avril
2021 la question des appâts l'accès et
le partage des avantages
de la biodiversité peut selon nous être
également réglé dans le cadre actuel en
revanche aller plus loin et écrire le
sénat coutumier certainement ma
nécessité de sortir du cadre
institutionnel parce que ça va faire
appel à d'autres définitions de
compétences mais pour l'instant j'ai
envie de dire que ce n'est pas la
priorité
ni par le Grand Conseil que tu lui dis
ni par les membres du de l'établissement
public de coopération que nous sommes en
train de mettre en place mais si il
s'avérait dans un avenir proche que cela
soit nécessaire de nos campagnes bien
évidemment de faire appel à qui de droit
pour que cette question soit placée au
cœur de nos préoccupations
tout ça pour dire que l'évolution
satuaire de la Guyane selon nous selon
les élus de Guyane et désormais
car les fils internes que nous ne
cessons
depuis le début de cette entretien sans
vraiment prégnants ce sont des défis qui
s'opposent à nous au niveau régional au
niveau international dans le cadre des
relations de coopération que nous devons
avoir avec les pays voisins au niveau
souvent le défi climatique qui va se
poser à la terre entière et dans la nuit
naturellement partie les défis
migratoires également ce que vous savez
que la Guyane depuis le design est
touché par une crise migratoire nous
devons pas très bien à quel moment cela
va cesser et tout ça bien évidemment sa
campagne du défi économique d'une
ampleur j'ai presque envie de dire il
est calé jusqu'à ce jour c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous considérons que nous
devons anticiper mais étant
l'anticipation il faut que nous soyons
parfaitement entendu par le gouvernement
il nous faut agir le très très vite pour
nous adapter en permanence à cet
environnement amazonienne qui peut être
porteur de tous les espoirs et dont on a
lui aussi qui de tous les toucher et je
pense notamment au phénomènes de
criminalité qui sévitent sur le
territoire la circulation des armes à
feu qui viennent du continent du
continent par dans une Américaine la
circulation des drones qui transitent
par la Guyane et cette circulation qui
fait de nous aujourd'hui
un pays qui est vu comme étant un grand
pont royaume de production alors que ces
produits ne font que transiter par le
territoire uadé avant que de prendre
l'avion vers l'Hexagone donc ce sont des
défis majeurs auxquels nous sommes
confrontés on a beaucoup parlé du défi
climatique parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plusieurs écoles qui s'affront c'est là
qui prétend que effectivement la
cuatrice de subir comme le monde entier
de toutes les conséquences négatives du
réchauffement climatique et puis
d'autres écoles qui prétend que au
contraire le plateau d'aigual pourrait
être un véritable refuge climatique pour
la terre et donc cela veut dire que dans
ce cas d'espèces la Guyane devrait
s'attendre à avoir un fluide sur ses
côtes un nombre très important de
climatique pour lesquels aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes pas prêts du tout donc
cela veut dire que dans le travail
d'anticipation qui n'était de l'autre il
nous faut mettre ça dans l'espace c'est
le des questions que nous nous posons de
pouvoir comment nous serons en capacités
de répondre favorablement à cette
demande concernant le rôle de l'État
c'est la question de comment jugez-vous
le rôle et la compagnement de l'État
pour exercer
vos compétences alors c'est le sujet
c'est le principal sujet de discussion
que nous avons depuis quelques temps
avec le ministère des outre-mer et que
nous allons continuer à approfondir dans
les bois qui viennent puisque travailler
sur la question de l'évolution
statutaire de la Guyane ne doit pas du
tout nous exodérer de travailler à
l'amélioration du cadre financier et
notamment de travailler à la suite de la
construction annuelle dans le cadre de
cette contractualisation qui a été mise
en place entre entre la collectivité et
le territoriale de Guyane et l'État qui
aujourd'hui un langage qui selon nous
n'est pas assez clair sur l'appui
d'autant effectivement porté dans le
cadre du prochain contrat de convergence
et de transformation du territoire pour
tout ce qui concerne l'aménagement du
territoire et notamment les
infrastructures routières vous savez que
la Guyane c'est une territoire de 84000
km² vaste comme le Portugal avec des
communes qui sont très éloignées de la
bonne littorale où se trouve Cayenne la
ville capitale les communes qui le sont
accessibles que par les airs soient
l'hélicoptère sur la viande ou alors par
les voies fluviales et aujourd'hui un
titre d'exemple vous avez la commune de
marie-passoula qui se trouve sur le
fleuve Maroni qui nous sépare du
juridique qui ne sépare du Suriname
c'est une commune qui est également
gravée et où les habitants portés par
collectif organise des manifestations de
blocage les avions ne peuvent pas
attirer depuis plus de trois semaines et
c'est vraiment parce que les acteurs de
mon être mieux prises en charge il
demande à ce que leur commune soit
davantage des enclavés ce problème
savoir que la Nua ne souffre de ce
désenclavagements qui est historique ça
fait plus de 400 ans que l'État français
puissent le territoire guyanais et il a
produit environ 400 km de route
seulement donc il y a là une vraie
problématique concernant les
infrastructures routières qui devraient
être pris en charge de à la fois par la
collectivité et par l'État il faudrait
véritablement que dans le cadre du
contrat de convergence et de
transformation l'état puisse se
positionner différemment que ce qu'il a
pu faire jusqu'à maintenant sur la
déconcentration de savoir est-ce qu'elle
permet
suffisamment l'état territoriale d'être
propre politique dans ce domaine de
compétence au contexte local juridique
économique sociale culturel de beauté de
citer quelques exemples mais pour aller
à l'essentiel et pour aller vite je
souhaiterais citer des exemples c'est un
le réseau qui est de c'est la lutte anti
vectorielle concernant le réseau routier
ou comme c'est le cas de l'Hexagone
l'état de confié à la région la
compétence mais garde les axes
stratégiques
sauf que c'est souvent le réseau
territorial de nous apprendre la
responsabilité qui trop souvent sert de
ou de secours
aux axes qui ont
la route nationale
ça devrait scandale parce que nous avons
des routes nationales qui ne ressemble
qu'à des chevaux vicinaux ou à des
chemins communaux sur d'autres parties
du territoire national et donc en nous
demande de faire des efforts nous
contribuons à notre façon à entretenir
le réseau de route départementale qui
sont donc devenus des routes
territoriales mais à côté de ça le
réseau national qui souffre d'une
situation extrêmement dégradée n'est pas
suffisamment n'est pas du tout
correctement prises en considération par
les services de l'État donc qui ont fait
des fois des transferts de compétences
mais sans faire les transferts de moyens
qui vont avec et ça depuis que le
regretté concernant le deuxième point
que je voulais s'y donner un exemple
c'est la lutte dont il vectorielle il y
a une loi récente qui entend tirer les
conséquences d'une gestion d'une
répartition hasardeuse des compétences
et aujourd'hui notre ARS ne cherche à
garder
des critiques qui normalement aurait dû
être quand il est différemment pour
financer ses propres politiques
publiques et ne pas être en capacité de
pouvoir les mettre au service de la
lithotine vectorielle qui est évolue à
la CTG créé également relatif à ce
niveau donc nous sommes en discussion
avec notre RS pour pouvoir comment on
peut arriver à tirer les conclusions
permettant d'aller vers une meilleure
gestion de ses critiques au bénéfice du
territoire
la révision des révisant oui c'est la
révision des articles 73 et 74 de la
Constitution
aller vers une fusion de ces deux
articles ouvrant la foi des statues sur
mesure et la fin de l'indicapi
historique donc comme quelqu'un de vrai
filmer quand tenu de notre vision de
l'avenir et six semaines de la Guyane je
voudrais simplement dire que c'est cadre
juridique et l'article 73 et l'article
74 pour les territoires qui sont exercés
ont montré tout simplement leurs limites
et nous pensons que leur
permettra pas nécessairement de lui
laisser les limites je crois que
plusieurs territoires d'outre-mer déjà
dépassé ces cadres même si ils ont été
attachés d'autres cadres juridiques ce
sont des expériences qui ont débouché
sur des conclusions plus ou moins
heureuses et je crois que l'essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est
de permettre de chaque territoire ne
soit capacités de crier
le cadre institutionnel qui tiennent
compte de
la différenciation nécessaire entre les
outre-mer et l'Hexagone c'est
véritablement l'objet du débat sur
lequel commencer avec le gouvernement
mais effectivement il est important de
ne pas oublier que la fête du cadre se
sont centré sur 14 ne signifie pas la
fête du statut de région ultra
périphérique ou le statut de pays notre
bien c'est le principal le garde-fou
auquel nous on sent car aujourd'hui les
normes de communautaires sont beaucoup
plus nombreuses que les normes
nationales et il faut savoir aussi que
les crédits et le communautaires sont
déterminants dans le cadre de la mise en
application des différentes politiques
publiques auxquelles nous participons
donc il est important que ce garde-fou
soit bien mise en place que ce n'est pas
parce que en irait vers autre chose que
ces deux articles j'ai envie de dire
historique que sur le 73 et le 74 que
cela devrait produire à la provocation
de ces statuts de rue j'ai dit ouais
mais je crois que les échanges que nous
avons eu avec les différents ministres
en parfaitement montrés qui sont
vraiment sensibles de à cette question
et que tout sera mise en place pour
éviter justement ce qui pourrait être
rapidement un véritable accident de
parcours et une véritable catastrophe
dans nos territoires pourraient avoir
beaucoup de mal à se relever sur
la différenciation entre les notions on
fait sur les différences entre les
notions de différenciation de
responsabilisation je crois que je ne
suis pas forcément le plus à même de
faire le cours de droit sur cette
question là mais
je vais vous envoyer également par écrit
les propositions et qui m'ont été faites
par le cabinet et qui m'accompagne et
qui rappelle selon la Constitution les
différences qui sont prévues dans le
droit de la différenciation la notion de
responsabilisation et la notion
d'autonomie mais on a dit à éviter je
pense que c'est le l'élément crucial sur
lequel nous allons travailler dans les
semaines et tous les mois qui viennent
l'autonomie c'est vraiment ce mot la
capacité à se forger c'est beaucoup lois
c'est propre aux règles et ses propres
valeurs je crois que l'industrie du
marché nous est d'accord pour se dire
que c'est la direction qu'il faut
prendre c'est d'ailleurs la définition
qu'on donne le Gérard contenu dans son
vocabulaire juridique et on veut
vraiment se raccrocher à cette
définition en disant que
de plus d'autonomie c'est à dire qu'elle
a vraiment besoin de décider de ses
propres lois pays dans certaines
matières autres bien sûr que celles qui
sont dévoluent à l'état ce qui voudrait
dire qu'on pourrait avoir trois types de
sources législatives vers le long terme
les sources qui concernent des matières
des polluent à l'état naturellement
resteraient dans le Giro de l'état de
l'histoire des matières qui sont
partagées entre l'État et une agréable
donc les chutes de la vie entre les deux
et puis l'essence qui seraient
problématiquesment
qu'on appellerait des lois pays qui
seraient
de la responsabilité de l'assemblée de
Guyane mais tout ça comme je vous l'ai
dit madame vous les enverras par
courrier pour que vous ayez une lecture
de très précise de la façon dont les
choses étaient entendues chez nous
qu'attendez-vous du descriptif de la
Guyane de la Constitution en tant que
collectivités
par le Congrès du médecin
14 de
article
de répondre est-il pas à vous objectifs
alors nous pensons que ça du
sujet des risques statut sur mesure
serait tout à fait capable de répondre à
la problématique
les constituants le vieux pour notre
développement et social je crois que
c'est ce que nous disons c'est ce que
nous ne cessons de répéter depuis de
très très nombreuses années beaucoup de
prises de
gens également de dire à quel point est
considéré que la configuration de
l'annuaire que son éloignement de
français hexagonale que cette
caractéristique
de Franck ce territoire devrait pouvoir
bénéficier de statuts qui nous
ressemblent qui sera accouché assez
vérités le statut d'automobile
permettrait effectivement de rédiger ses
lois pays on a dit en la répéter et on a
vraiment à chaque fois le sentiment
d'une rivosité de la part de nos
différents gouvernements successifs à
pouvoir raconter une réative à cette
revendication et tant que je me dis
pourquoi ne pas consulter de cette belle
opportunité qui nous est offerte
aujourd'hui pour que avec vous la
délégation sénatoriale aux autres mais
avec aussi de l'Assemblée nationale
prendre le temps de faire
écouter qui soit
plus simple pour que cette fois que le
montant soit mieux entendu par Paris
question 14 et suivi vous que le statut
européen du régime 3 périphérique
pourrait être fragilisé par une
évolution des compétences
de la Guyane
excusez-nous en vous entend plus
vous nous entendez
on essaie
maintenant c'est revenu
je pense que c'est parce que j'ai trop
mal
de la technique
sur ce le statut de rue
alors je disais que nous n'avons qu'une
quête par rapport à ça
on se base bien évidemment sur le statut
des régions espagnol ou portugaise
et son côté d'une très très forte
méthodologie qui n'ont pas pour autant
perdu leur statut de région
ultra périphériques de l'Union
européenne même si nous pensons que cela
pose des conquêtes différentes en
fonction des territoires on a beaucoup
évoqué la question
du carburant par exemple vous la
question concernant la trajectoire de
bicarbonation de l'économie la question
qui a été à l'ordre du jour des
débats que nous avons eu dernièrement et
qui font certainement nécessiter que une
approche une distanciée soit mise en
oeuvre mais globalement il n'y a aucune
crainte si l'intelligence toute
circonstances que ce statut de rue ne
soit écourné par l'évolution du cadre
syndicaire dans le cadre du schéma
national que nous souhaitons que nous
souhaitons écrire
la population adverselle à la
perspective d'une évolution des
institutions ou à une extension des
compétences une possible révision
constitutionnelle susciter des
inquiétudes ou des espoirs
mon travail en tant que président de la
société sera bénévénement d'apporter les
réponses aux inquiétudes réelles ou
supposées de la population et je
reconnais que pour la première fois
angulaine le processus entre les élus la
population civile les différents corps
constitués semblent se dessiner donc on
est plutôt sur un par rapport à cette
problématique bien évidemment que on
s'est noté d'une cellule Communication
qui aura pour mission d'aller sur le
terrain pour faire le travail
d'explication pour que la population que
les électeurs soient au lieu de leur
capacité de compréhension du processus
que nous avons entamé et donc nous
considérons que si le travail des
formations et de communication est
correctement réalisée
la population s'y oppose contrairement à
ce que nous espérions lors des
consultations populaires du mois de
janvier 2010
la question c'est une amendement direct
inspiré les travaux de Michel
maghrebis etc
alors moi j'ai pas entendu jugement sur
la critique du travail qui avait été
réalisé par mon ami Michel agrafe parce
que j'ai considéré que c'est un
autrement constitué une excellente base
de travail qui était à nuisible de la
différenciation la difficulté que nous
avons relevée selon si on en a fait une
mauvaise lecture et vous ne le
pardonnerez si c'était le cas c'est
qu'il ne disait pas grand chose sur les
transferts les moyens humains et
témoignés financiers d'ailleurs nous
avons relevé
c'est un volontairement que le
questionnement actuel ne pose pas
d'interrogations sur la question des
financement mais nous sommes convaincus
que ça sera
[Musique]
à dire un élément essentiel du travail
que nous avons devoir réaliser pour
permettre à notre territoire d'évoluer
dans la direction de l'autonomie donc
pour ainsi dire le principe de cet
abonnement constitution nous que le très
bonnes bases de travail mais il faut le
faire évoluer vers actu
alisation
[Musique]
en parlant on en parlant de d'aspect
financier nous sommes en discussion avec
l'IGF et IgA pour voir comment on va
pouvoir informer la fiscalité de la cité
g et ça pourrait avoir une continuation
en direction de l'évolution sanitaire de
la nouvelle fiscalité qui pourrait
s'appliquer à notre territoire dans la
mesure où cette élément fondamental le
guide devrait s'il est correctement
présent de considération nous permettre
de mieux répondre aux aspiration de la
population
s'il y a une question qui peut faire des
basses et comment on va financer les
nouvelles compétences qui seront évolués
à la Guyane dans le cadre de ce nouveau
statut que nous savons pertinemment que
de tout temps l'État a toujours eu de
Lucie de faire le transfert de
compétences quand cela est intéressé
mais nos plus jamais le transfert des
moyens de financiers qui devaient
accompagner nous allons être extrêmement
vigilant sur cette question il y a des
fois en Guyane qui s'élèvent pour dire
que l'on pourrait taxer différemment
l'activité sociale alors je dis bien des
fois ce n'est pas la voix du réseau de
la ctchisme ce n'est pas non plus la
voix apporter par la somme des
territoriale puisque cette question n'a
pas encore été mise sur la table mais on
vous le dit comme ça que vous le sachiez
il a des fois aussi qui s'élève pour que
la Guyane puisse récupérer une partie de
tout l'argent qui est passé sur le
marché des quotas carbone puisque nos
84000 km² de forêt
[Musique]
donc voilà on n'est pas on n'est pas au
bout de la réflexion mais il est évident
que il nous va nous falloir trouver les
moyens dans le cadre juridique qui nous
est parti pour améliorer de façon très
sensible au niveau de nos sources
financières
alors il y a aussi les poissons le fait
de remarquer parce que je parlais de
leur PSG légale mais on pourrait aussi
parler de la pêche légal qui les
ressources s'alutiques de la Guyane
alors souvent le poisson qui est saisi
sur les tapis brésilienne ou peut-être
l'état privé
à la mer parce que il ne souhaite pas
conserver donner conditions en forme aux
exigences européennes à titre d'exemple
maintenant ce que c'est 12 Stone
nous sommes de poissons ont été rejetés
à la verrue hier nous sommes persuadés
que c'est ce sont des produits que l'on
pourrait récupérer et les introduire
dans des cycles de transformation pas
nécessairement pour la consommation
humaine mais pour la commission de Farid
animal autre chose moi je ne sais pas il
y a comme ça des solutions auxquelles on
pourrait réfléchir et qui certainement
pourraient permettre de pouvoir évoluer
favorablement sur ce type
voilà je suis désolé si je n'ai pas
respecté le temps que vous m'aviez de
partir au départ je vais terminer
madame je vous remercie monsieur le
Président c'était vraiment très très
éclairant votre exposé je reviendrai
juste sur
la question des transferts financiers
vous seriez donc favorable à ce que la
Constitution précise l'obé l'obligation
de contractualisation avec l'État pour
accompagner ces transferts de
compétences
tout à fait puisque ils n'ont pas
imaginer que l'État cherchera à se
débarrasser de certaines compétences qui
seraient devenu des fardeaux on a une
signale qui nous dit que la batterie est
faible
demander le technicien de voir comment
donc c'est vrai que je l'ai dit je l'ai
dit précédemment il a passé 30 ans que
normalement les transferts de
compétences
ne sont pas accompagnés de transferts
des moyens qui devaient laver ou alors
le transfert s'est fait le transfert des
moyens c'est fait à un instant alors que
on s'est bien rendu compte que dans la
foulée les moyens allaient en
s'accroissant parce que hésiter
précieusement indexés sur la courbe
d'évolution de la population et là
dessus on se dit que oui il faut que
dans la rédaction qui sera mise en
oeuvre de cette question sans poser et
que l'on s'a à trouver une réponse qui
sera construite à nos attentes au
développement de nos territoires
respectifs
pourriez-vous préciser s'il vous plaît
si vous souhaitez toujours la Guyane et
son titre propre dans la Constitution
comme la Nouvelle-Calédonie ou bien un
statut à l'état à la carte dans le cadre
de l'article 74 comme la Polynésie
suffit-il
je vais faire une CPS de cébusité parce
que nous avions dit que il nous faut un
statut à la cape on ne veut pas être
dans un cadre le cadre généraliste
en disant que chacun va pouvoir faire sa
petite visiteur et de nous considérons à
l'eau de ce qui s'est passé depuis que
la Guyane doit pouvoir être inscrite
dans la Constitution et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y a une résolution du
congrès du 26 mars qui dit très
exclusivement que nous souhaiterions que
la graine fasse objet d'une inscription
à l'intérieur de titre 12 pistes de la
Constitution qui lui serait
excessivement dédié donc c'est la
formulation que nous avions retenu pour
exprimer
et c'est la base sur laquelle je vous
annonce le continuer à travailler avec
le gouvernement dans le processus de
co-construction que nous avons démarré
il y a pas ça
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur et
je terminerai juste par une par une
information
concernant les rupes et les
Saint-Barthélémy et Saint-Martin par
exemple sont deux collectifs première
régie par l'article 74
pourtant l'une
porte est
parlons l'une à le statut de PTOM et
l'autre a le statut de région ultra
périphérique donc c'est tout à fait
possible d'avoir un statut au titre
national et statut particulier au titre
de l'Union européenne
tout à fait on en a discuté amplement
avec le président de la collectivité de
ces 20e
qui nous expliquait facilités
[Musique]
mais en même temps ce que je lui disais
c'est que la Guyane également étant si
particulière
des temps pas assimilable à une autre de
ces régions territoire d'outre-mer que
nous souhaiterions véritablement être en
capacité de mener la réflexion de mener
une réflexion qui ne soit pas au cours
de laquelle on va mettre sur la table ce
que nous sommes réellement expliciter
auprès du gouvernement la nécessité que
nous soyons aux entendus sur une base
qui soit conforme à nos attentes qui
s'inspiraient bien évidemment de ceux
qui ont réussi à réaliser les autres
territoires aussi bien les pays où même
les rues de France en particulier que je
le citerai précédemment les régions
ultra périphériques du Portugal
je vais aller voir comment fonctionner
la Sardaigne puisque je me dis que la
sardine est un territoire
tellement personnel on entend parler et
on s'est dit que
on ne vous entend plus à nouveau désolé
regardez faire
vous avez sûrement quelques problèmes de
réseau
churé
vous nous entendez
vous nous
on ne vous entend pas non plus
vous voulez vous pouvez leur écrire un
message
[Musique]
nous sommes vraiment navré mais je crois
que
il y a un gros problème de son oui nous
aussi nous vous entends pas
vous entendez
vous pouvez parler s'il vous plaît
madame
vous m'entendez très bien merci
donc monsieur le Président je suis né un
vrai on ne vous a pas entendu on n'a pas
entendu la fin de votre propos si vous
voulez reprendre et puis nous clôturons
ensuite
j'étais en train de dire que nous avons
l'intention de nous rapprocher de
certaines territoires pour voir comment
les choses se passent chez eux et
j'étais en train de citer la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais la police
française la Corse la sardine également
je pense que rien ne nous empêche de
nous rapprocher de ses pieds et
Nouvelle-Calédonie
du fonctionnement
territoires voilà
je vous remercie infiniment c'était
vraiment nous avons vraiment appris
énormément de choses avec vous sur la
Guyane et nous espérons poursuivre ce
travail en collaboration avec vous
merci beaucoup
de ce que j'ai dit aujourd'hui
l'essentiel en tout cas parce qu'il y a
des éléments
que je n'ai pas sur ma petite feuille de
préparation mais on va vous faire
de ce qui merci beaucoup bon courage
dans la suite de
votre mission j'espère que cela vous ira
favorablement à ce que le gouvernement
arrive à comprendre le les attentes de
nos différents territoires pour que les
réponses espérés par la population soit
tout à fait au rendez-vous
je vous remercie au revoir au revoir